good evening members and officers of the
council
um and members of the public welcome to
this meeting of governance and audit
committee uh just a little bit of
housekeeping and the fire alarm
procedures if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices by
the stairs please do not use the list
assemble in Hawley Square on the green
officers will assist you and advise you
when it is steam safe to return to the
chamber filming does anyone intend to
film the meeting
nope perfect
um restrictions of mobile phones um
would everyone please present please
ensure their mobile phones are turned to
silence and that they are not used to
make or receive phone calls in the
chamber while the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will be recorded and will
subsequently broadcast on the council's
YouTube channel
are there any moments who wish to speak
under Council procedure rule 20.1
there's no members
um I'll just move on to a gender item
one apologies for absence
um there have been apologies received
from councilor Braidwood and councilor
Pat Moore who's been substituted by
councilor Yates
and moving to a gender item are there
any other apologies for absence
um decorations of Interest are there any
Declarations of Interest
nope
Legend item 3 minutes of the meeting
held on the 28th of September 2022 to
approve the minutes of the meeting held
on 20th September 22 to copy attach the
agenda pack please can I have a proposal
and a second up
councilor Duckworth
uh yeah there was a just a bit missing
from the minutes page
seven item number six as part of the
discussion on the complaints procedures
I did suggest the flowchart to help
residents make complaints
um this wasn't necessary about
individuals
um but more so that we we've got an
opportunity for residents to help us
shed a light on where things can fall
through the net in our systems but
basically
um that was a suggestion I made in
discussion raising the following points
if that could be added in please
yeah and if members are happy with that
um can we have a proposal and a seconder
proposed by a councilor shrub seconded
by councilor Duckworth and let's hear
any objection I will take these as
approved
moving on to a gender item 4 an update
on corporate property issues Mark piece
would you please provide your update
hi everyone I'm the interim property
director I joined in July so my work is
only five months in
um but I was asked to look at how we
would
um in our resourcing uh the ways in
which we can
um
secure the maximum amount of
Revenue that we might might well have
been losing previously
and I've also looked at some statutory
compliance issues as well that we're
that we're addressing
um so a brief bit of background for
those
um not
aware
um all right we've got a mixed use
portfolio I deal with the non-housing
assets or the commercial assets there's
727 of them in all some of them are just
land but there are 338 active sites
within the portfolio
um
for the purpose of this exercise I've
taken the general fund I've taken
Portland Harbor and the HRA properties
they are they are just the telecoms and
a master above those properties so the
nuts and bolts of it is we've got a
current rental income of about 2.2
million pounds per annum yet the
estimated rental value of our portfolio
is about
3.14 so we're about a million pounds
short in what we could be collecting
and one of the issues that we've got is
that there are 200 outstanding lease
renewals and rent reviews
and many of those outstanding rent
reviews
um are predated from 2016 so some of
them are six years out of date
so the good news is that's a lot of
opportunity
to get Revenue in and if you look at the
three different
um funds that we work with if port and
harbor and HRA are on
um normally are in standard
uh indexed rent reviews therefore
there's not too much discrepancy there
but in the general fund there's
um they are
reviews to market value and as I
outlined before we have
um
about 200 properties where people are in
occupation but they haven't or their
leases have expired and they require
lease renewals before we can enact those
Rim reviews
I've put in here a little bit of
information about Capital receipts which
come from disposals which is relevant
later on when we talk about funding the
repairs and maintenance
in the portfolio
um
in addition to rent I think we have
issues in the portfolio
that we need to address there's a
significant backlog of repairs and
maintenance and statutory compliance
which needs to do
um
and part of the problem with that most
normal portfolios would have a plan
maintenance schedule which you would
just update on it on a yearly basis
due to the Staffing shortages that we've
had in the high turnover of Staff in the
department we don't have uh that
scheduled to hand so we've had to go out
over
um the 350 active properties and
commission cost surveys and condition
surveys I've outlined the ones that
we've already commenced in a and we've
also got approval to do another 20 major
condition surveys
and I've given some example
so
and it is a risk so we don't know fully
until we get those reports back which
will be costed
um the two costs of those works so
I've been estimating and what we have
had back from the surveys that we've had
back in the surveyors that have been
around the properties is that last year
we were had 115 000 this is in the
general fund not the harbor armor or the
HRA but in the general fund 115
000 was allocated for repairs and
maintenance
um I estimate next year that figure will
will be about a million pounds higher
1.1138 there's good and bad news and
that's obviously bad news in that we're
having to expend that money but good
news and we're not we're putting those
properties into uh well hopefully is a
safe or at least the wind and water type
condition
um statutory compliance is obviously a
big issue for all of us
and we recruited in September an asset
compliant officer
he's already identified 125 properties
which require energy performance
certificates
and we've added another two EPC firms to
the supplier list
and now we have engaged three firms to
carry out the priority one
epcs and that completion of that work is
anticipated at the end of January
from then we will then have a better
idea although I have estimated in that
repairs and maintenance schedule
an estimate of that work on an average
based on other properties who fall below
level E on the EPC register
so
with the asset compliance officer coming
we've done
a number of site inspections and he's
got an ongoing case to try and cover the
majority of the portfolio and already
he's highlighted eight additional risks
which have been added to the Estates
registered Jackie Baker's Pavilion
Tivoli and a few others are examples of
those
um
we're beginning to get to grips with
these
um states that compliant register it
wasn't in a great condition I have to
say when when we joined but we're now
working with Bob's team they've got the
two compliance software package which
works very well on the housing and we're
trying to transfer that over although
without running the risk of corrupting
Bob's data so try and set it up
separately for ourselves
so the um
how are we going to do it well obviously
the conditioned surveys and the EPC
surveys and a financial allowance for
those works is one way that's physical
resourcing but the most important thing
I think is the human resourcing
um so in the relevant departments that
are focusing on on income and direct
Asset Management
as up first of June which which was a
month before I joined you had two estate
surveyors one interim an acquisition
disposal surveyor and a rent officer so
they just had four people carrying out
that function which is monumentally
understaffed
um we've done quite well obviously we've
recruited myself we've got we've
recruited two additional estate
surveyors
um both interim and the asset compliance
officer I referred to earlier
up to the end of this financial year we
have approval which needs to be
finally signed off for in cabinet on on
the 15th
um but it's um
cost neutral because of the rent reviews
that they'll be doing we will and we're
out in the market currently for two more
estate surveyors on an interim basis and
there will be income focused
then from the next financial year up to
March 24 obviously we're hoping to
retain All the Above
but add on three estate surveyors and
they will be split between
Asset Management which is the more
strategic side of it and including
disposals
a compliance orientated person to
support the person that we've already
got and an audit data management
specialist
I mean we'll have four
project
decarbonization repairs and capital
staff
that again to be confirmed
um
at the budget Council I believe in
February
um that's it if anybody's got any
questions I'm happy to answer
thank you Mark members any questions
councilor Garner
thank you thank you for that um
quite enlightening presentation it's
it's quite a lot to take in actually I'm
without having seen it before we came
along to the meeting
but a couple of
a couple of things
I mean I'd like I'd like us to have the
opportunity actually if you don't mind
to come back to this after we've had a
time to digest all of this because I
think there's quite a lot in there of
concern
um but a couple of heart would it be up
would you be able to go back to one of
the first slides I think the second or
third
fire the right right near there there
okay that one yeah
so
just for clarification for me so what
what you're saying here is that we've
been missing out on
three quarters of a million pounds a
year of from the of the potential rental
of the properties that we own as far as
the general fund is concerned
and how how many years is that for
huh
it is a great meeting if you go back to
the Tennessee schedule and look at it
and the data and you've got the average
time
that some of the last print oh I'm sorry
yeah so sorry uh the the average time I
think that some of the last rent reviews
were done as an average was about around
about 2018 so somewhere with some about
four years out not on all of them
um but but about on average about four
years that's on some of this
particularly on beach concessions and
smaller items because we just haven't
had the staff to do it
um and there are some that predate 2016.
okay
thanks
though I did have a couple of more
questions
an extra comment to that just to that
question yeah um I I would say I just
think we need to be a little bit
cautious about seeing that figure and
thinking oh that's all income that uh is
potentially available and could you know
help solve some of the council's
financial pressures
um
there absolutely isn't and Mark's right
that's potential additional rent stream
income from the property portfolio
however the reason that that portfolio
is underperforming is that the team
haven't had the staff
to renew leases and to review rents and
to get those into payment and the
proposals that we've put through the
style chamber process and we'll be
incorporated into the budget
um
the vast majority of that Gap
effectively is needed to fund the
resources that are required in the team
so we'll get to a point where you know
we'll the the portfolio is performing
but our costs of managing the portfolio
have gone up
um in the longer term we think there's
potentially further gains that could
create some Financial benefits but in
the short to medium term what we're
really talking about is
um creating the Headroom to be able to
increase the size of the team to the
level that's needed to do the job that
is required in managing over 700 assets
okay thanks thanks yeah I I understand
that uh now better thank you thanks for
that explanation
um
but I guess
Why by comment would be though that this
it's it's all it's all been reviewed now
if this had been done
I don't know I'll use the word correctly
over a period of time we wouldn't be in
the position we are now so if this had
been correctly managed
from 2016 and before and we'd been
building up the team that we've required
to manage these properties we wouldn't
be in the position we are now and we
would have been able to we would have
been able to benefit from being able to
maximize the potential of the property
and I'm not saying that we would be one
million pound better off because a lot
of that would be
costs for Staffing and such like but if
we'd better manage this over a period of
time then we would we we wouldn't have
to be in the position of now looking to
spend a lot of money that we don't as
you say we don't have so as we can get
into a position we should have been in
at the beginning of that period is sort
of the way
I'm beating it anyway
um
but the other one of the other things I
I heard you say was about
um lease renewal at least renewals so
the number of lease leases haven't been
renewed
um but I didn't quite understand does
that mean that where Elise has come to
the end and they haven't been reviewed
those occupants
who were at least in that property have
left
or then they're actually some occupants
still in property
but aren't paying their lease because
the lead we haven't had the staff to
renew their leases and review their
leases and
that's very very good question
um
it's a mixture of both so
I thought we had
oh uh that's a good question
um
in in and that's half half true half
half not true
um so when your lease expires and you
haven't got a new lease you're what's
known as holding over
some councils like Kent don't charge any
rent at all for fear of giving us making
a statutory tendency
than it does
but when we're coming to certain
situations like a rent review I can
think of a sorry one where one sir has
got involved in recently and they're
paying a rent that's eight years out of
date which which is a quarter of what
the current market value is because the
lease hasn't been renewed
and under the under the terms and the
rent reviews haven't been carried out so
um it's a difficult question and there's
also another question which I I think
you might be thinking of
well if are we looking to back date that
rent
um it's a very good question
um I don't think in the economic Market
you can because if I'm honest that's due
to
the mismanagement by ourselves and it's
not the current tenant's faults and if
you're going back date it too far
there's legislation which prevents you
from doing that at least prevents you
too because some of some of the rent
reviews have to be done on top on
specific times
but what we are tending to do is if it's
12 months go back 12 months like
effectively to a beginning of a year
that we're doing it and in that case the
tenants have been more willing to pay a
full rent which helps us going forwards
rather than if you back date it
rics regulations would tend to resist
you doing
full Market rent back day to four or
five years it's just not fair on the
tenant
unless you've been in legislation
against them and they've been in court
resisting the rent so
um the the furthest at the moment I'm
instructing my surveyors to go back is
12 months
okay thank you so so we we you are
saying then we do currently have tenants
who aren't paying any rent because their
leases haven't been reviewed and they
haven't got a um and they haven't got
the vents updated this and where they
were the leases were ended they were
paying rents that because they had been
reviewed were lower than they could have
been and that all sort of adds up to the
Gap that was shown on the on the
previous slide okay so all right I mean
there are
I mean it's quite an issue in the main
solid in the middle in the main we are
collecting rent where you have trouble
is if the lease hasn't been renewed it's
very difficult to charge a service
charge so for the electric and and um
other Heating and all those sorts of
things if there isn't um a valid current
lease in place so it impacts in other
areas the other issue just to say about
the positive side looking forwards if
you don't put oil in your car
and then the analogy being with prepare
repairing a property then you get a
bigger breakdown cost than if you were
doing the repair so some of our
buildings have got accumulated
um repair maintenance items that would
be much less if we'd have attacked them
earlier in the process
so it's going to I think going to be a
painful year to at least to try and
catch up on the repairs and maintenance
but when we've done that
and the additional Staffing in place to
do that and we have plan preventative
maintenance schedules hopefully on all
of our buildings then the the net
outgoings to us will be much less the
the value of the properties will
increase and therefore the rental values
will go up with those properties so that
in I hope in about 18 months time the
net value of the property portfolio
should go up considerably
okay thank you I mean I do see
a yeah I can see the positive in this I
mean we can't fix a problem until we've
fully identified and got it got it out
on the on the table so to speak so now
it is out on and we do unders or we're
getting to understand the scale of the
issue then we can
tackle it and resolve it but it's
obviously gonna like you say it's going
to be quite a lot of pain budget wise
um especially and especially in the
current market where you're you're
mentioning about not being able to
charge
um for services like electricity and gas
well the bills to us are going to be
going up and up and up aren't they so
it's going to be costing us even more to
service these properties that we're not
able to to collect the service charge
off of people for so thank you
just a quick comment sorry sorry
um on the budget the figures in the
report in the slides
um we have based the figures on
um the information that we've fed into
the budget build for next year obviously
that still needs to be approved
um but there are proposals coming
forward for how we will meet some of
those costs
um
clearly I mean as as Mark said during
the presentation there are costs out
there that we don't currently know about
but the ones that we do know about where
we have been able to we've put them into
those figures
um so the way we don't know about them
obviously we'll need to have a longer
term plan for those
just went out Mark and Bob Mayberry to
articulated but the plan that we've got
in place it's almost a bit of a virtuous
circle by having the appropriate staff
in place we can generate the revenues
but fund the staff but then for allow us
to invest in our back into our
properties so that's that's the the long
term plan so hopefully it will it will
feed itself rather the situation we
found ourselves in which has been a a
vicious cycle or a bit of a death spiral
or Doom cycle as a council it's like to
refer to well we've not had appropriate
staff so we've not been able to collect
the rent and we've not been able to
invest in the the asset so we're
flipping that round now and we should be
able to address the um the issues that
um Mark and Bubba referred to
yeah thanks I mean sorry just one other
thing I guess one thing we do need to do
is learn lessons from this how we've got
into this or how we've allowed ourselves
to get into this position how how over
the years we haven't
why haven't we tackled this previously
you know and why what what could we have
done differently so as we don't get into
this sort of position again
um I think it's a very good question
obviously when you're in a situation you
want to be learning the lessons my
assessment of it would be it's
um
symptomatic of the savings that the
councils had to make over the last 10
years in terms of reducing the size of
an establishment and the planet's not
alone in it lots of councils find the
situation in where there's been
um compound or accumulated salami slices
to support services and departments
across the
um the organization where the
organization hasn't really stopped
providing anything we're just doing it
with a smaller number of Staff we're
still providing pretty much the same
range of services that we were a decade
ago but with a much smaller staff cohort
to deliver that and what that does it
exposes us to risks and unfortunately
this is the um you know the the
manifestation of one of those risks in
terms of the state of our property
portfolio
Council towning
I'd like to thank you for coming along
today Mark it's a long overdue subject
that we've wanted to address for some
time that it's a very important area of
the income for the council You Know It
uh it generates a well-being for the
council to do a lot of other things
um on the basis of the Holy over of your
leases uh how many of them are
historical to 2016. do you know
I do know whether there are retail or
whether they are commercial offices and
what would be the new basis of your rent
review on what is the market values that
you're looking at per square footage or
rental of or retail and on Commercial
Marketplace of offices or I likewise
yeah that's that's that's a very good
question
um it's a very broad portfolio of quite
I would say that
maybe 70 of those
um if you want to call it arrears or or
like a rent
in concessions side if would you call
that retail
but at the beach concessions we've been
a bit slow on that
um difficult situation we inherited at
Harbor arm as you know
um that that were just up to 13
properties there were just two leases in
place so how would you go and put a rent
review and if there's no lease in place
the tenants are
resisting paying rent until we saw our
issues with the toilets and with
um the roof and various other things
um
so it's it's a lot of time and effort
for somebody to come in and sort that
just that little example out
um and
um
so I I would say it's largely
um in terms of
the areas the ones
like Rob yates's company is easy that's
on an indexation basis and uh it's very
straightforward that's why Harbor arm
has less arrears than
um than than the general fund portfolio
um you know
I I it's more a market commentary than
anything else but if industrial is not
seeing such a Slowdown at all so I think
those rents are holding firm the the
ones that are suffering are your out and
out retail properties on on high streets
people aren't coming in covid
scuffled it it's online trading we're
trying to
regenerate areas trying to get the
Ramsgate Market
um back up again and we had a good
meeting on that
um today with Laura and Steve Alban
um but the offices is an interesting one
um if you've got car parking and they're
and they're well maintained and in a
good location I think there's still
demand for those although people are
more comfortable with hybrid home
working now but the the real and and
there's quite a lot of demand for the
beach concessions there's quite an
entrepreneurial culture here and and and
and people want to have a go
um but
High Street properties of which we don't
have too many are a problem for everyone
at the moment
um
with regards to the toilets
it's a it's a very personal thing for me
because I I look after you know but as
much as Rob does as well you know
um you know we have visitors as you live
in the summer and toilets are a massive
issue uh throughout uh turnips you know
and have you actually are you going to
organize a complete survey to get a
schedule of works and then have them
costed uh fairly urgently
um if you look on number a there
um that's one survey fifth all 54 public
toilets uh I've I've been now about to
be commissioned and we've gone through
the procurement process uh and that's a
piece of work
um that is is
probably got three arms to it there's a
number of town councils who've expressed
interest in taking back some some
toilets there's
um potential for the the beach
orientated toilets to go into one
particular management but we don't want
to put them in there without saying look
this is the outstanding repairs this is
what we expect within a period of time
for them to be repaired and then there
will need to be a discussion about the
the Inland what I call the Inland public
toilets about what we're going to do
with them but whether we put them on the
open market whether they go to town
councils or whether we continue to
operate them but you can't have a
sensible conversation about that until
you've got this costed survey back
uh I I appreciate that uh the point is
that if we look at toilets all right
unless we're prepared to do the work to
the toilets that you're we're going to
find it very difficult to offload them
uh
uh so is there are we going to do work
to them or are we just going to try and
say to someone well we give you a period
of red free to repair uh and and then
thereafter whatever the whatever the
arrangements are
what is it let's take it I'll take that
question
um to be honest that's that's a whole
separate piece of work so you know see
Marx team in managing the property
portfolio the first question is to
understand the condition of the assets
and so hence the the purpose of this
slide so I'd say inform you all about
the work that's going on to understand
the condition of our assets
um the potential options in future and
and range of things we might or could do
with the toilets is a is a different
thread of work and uh and Mark and I
aren't really the right people to answer
questions about that and obviously it
also includes
um issues about the cleaning of them the
supplies in them the management of them
not not just the conditions so they're
much bigger much more complex issues
than than just what the marks team are
working on currently
um obviously if if this committee is
interested in that then you know I'm
sure we could have conversations in the
future as as as work progresses but I
don't think it's something that Mark and
I can answer now
chair for me I think obviously it's a
interesting subject matter I think it's
important that we stay within the sort
of the room of this committee that for
me feels very much like a scrutiny topic
where we're looking at sort of policy
decisions and priorities for the
organization what um Mr Porter and this
piece are very well said as this the
plans that we've got in place the
controls have been in place to deliver
the objectives of the council around the
property portfolio rather than stepping
into the Realms of which particular
assets are we going to be looking to
dispose of which I think is a very
worthwhile topic but why my would
suggest is more well suited for for
scrutiny panel or a subgroup rather than
governance and audit committee
Council Elise
thank you um
under a on the condition and cost
surveys when are we likely to see the
results of those surveys
um and is it going to be a matter of
East peer Ramsgate Harbor's taken first
and so on and so forth or are they all
being done at the same time
um it is
Ramsgate has been done
um you know the condition of it is not
great but it's actually worse so it
looks worse than it is because some some
of that concrete was taken off in order
to view what was behind it and so it
hasn't actually fallen off
um but um so we've we've commissioned
that one uh the Winter Gardens is an
update one
um from a previous surveys that were
done
um and you get that back in a couple of
months North down house uh
um is about to be commissioned we're
taking that back off for your leisure as
you know
um Hearts down and Ramsgate Leisure
centers have been done now
um and they're going to form uh the
schedule of condition and The Works
Matrix with with your leisure the public
toilet was effectively signed off today
about who were going to procurement
process and I would expect the the
outcome the costed condition schedule of
that back um at the end of January
sorry just yeah just on that figure of
the 54 public toilets yeah yeah
obviously that's that can't be uh
the sites themselves is it I mean how is
that how many units there are no no it's
not cubicles no that that is how many
we've got 54 public toilet sites yes my
God
it's probably worth saying that they're
not all necessarily operational toilets
but they're buildings that are within
our portfolio that
um are operational tool it's all
previously were operational toilets or
you know um but they're not all
necessarily operational at this point
so far
you really you know we talked about you
raised this issue about the toilets no
it
would you love for you
um
the uh
in the summer I raised the issue about
the toilets and I was told there was a
review being taken by a councilor up at
the time have you seen that review
uh myself personally I've not seen the
review but I can't comment on the sort
of the existence or the progress that's
been made of the review that's something
you'd have to um take up with counselor
cup I'm afraid
because do you realize this is the third
review
um Ash Ashby which she was in in office
in 19 had a review then Steve uh all
boot came along he had a review and then
we've got another review I mean we need
to really push and find out where we are
with these reviews sure
I do believe Constantine that um there
was a request that the latest avian
scrutiny panel meeting that was for
Council cup to present to the next ons
meeting
um if not the next one the one after
that so I do believe that that will
probably be the best Forum to have that
discussion
um but moving on to council Yates
thank you chair and uh thank you Mark
for that presentation I think uh
hopefully speak for everyone here where
I say welcome to transparency and the
openness around us uh it's it's
refreshing uh to see that uh level of
detail about this issue
um
just a few questions so
is there any way that we as counselors
and members can
can keep our eye on this issue because I
know I've when I was in cabinet I was
asking for updates and not getting it
but is there any way to see how many
when reviews have we done on time per
quarter and keep those metrics
um that's my first question thanks
to produce that are you being relatively
new and so short stuff that it's been
quite a work of art to get to this this
level
um
now it's it's a kind of allocation and
prioritization
um I hate the term low-hanging fruit but
it is prudent in this instance to do
that
um but that
we've now just about got with four
um
experience asset surveyors enough to
hold the general day-to-day management
it's these two
um interim surveyors that were out in
the market for at the moment who are
going to really accelerate the rent
reviews because they've got a lot of
tenant issues that they're that they're
having to deal with
um so I
I would think we hope that we from the
end of this um Financial year to be able
to come back with meaningful data
um that's relevant without giving away
what our interpretation of Erv is we're
in the middle of a negotiation we've got
to be a little bit careful about that
and we're also quite sensitive and I
know when we meet with
um councilor Saunders too that this is
quite a tough time for retailers coming
out of covid and now coming into the
cost of living crisis and we're trying
to encourage Enterprise and employment
and that's another reason I don't really
want to go back six years on a rent
review for somebody who's just trying to
break even at the moment so
um
in answer to your question yes but but
not down to look that person's paying
500 pounds per annum will make go after
them for seven and a half thousand but
but to say but to say
um
the last quarter that there were 200
outstanding and we've now completed in
that quarter 50 or whatever that thing
certainly I can do that
yeah and that's the the very high level
overview I think which would be really
useful because
um
yeah that's that's relatively
straightforward yeah yeah perfect
um and yeah just going on to the point
of obviously you need resource to be
able to do just just that kind of level
of additional work so yeah I I for one
welcomed uh the hiring of these
additional posts and it's about time in
my opinion that this happened
um something that I've been I was
pushing for for years and
um it was a bit like slamming my head
against a brick wall to be honest trying
to get that which leads me on to my
second question
um so when we did take in the harbor arm
which you mentioned
um I was kind of hoping that we could
use that additional monies for uh the
Estates team and
uh hiring more people but I think at the
time we were told that it has to feel
like a budget black hole
um is it now the case that some of these
estate incomes can be used
um
for the staff additional staff thanks
I I I'll take that question
um
you know ultimately the the decision
about where resources in the budget are
allocated is the decision for full
Council to make
um
and and for cabinets a recommendable
council
um what that might look like for next
year and we've done a lot of work in
supporting Chris and his team in finance
um putting together the draft budget for
next year
and that specifically includes a
appraisal about the potential increases
in rent income from the portfolio and
how we might use that to support the
property service
so you know ultimately whether that
money is ring fence for that purpose or
not is is a decision for Council but the
proposals that
we've been working on and subject to
agreement at cabinet and subsequently
coming onto Council
that will include
the resourcing of the team that we think
we need to be able to deliver this
effectively
um so certainly for next year
realistically the best we could hope for
is that that is cost neutral but in the
longer term we do think there's
potential for some some resources that
could be freed back to the wider
objectives of the authority okay oh
thank you very much Bob and thank you
Mark I think that's what from my just my
feedback is really positive
um step forward thanks
yeah so
um I've realized there's governments are
not audit and we've got statutory
compliance duties and everything but
rightly so the salaries that we've put
forward for 23.24
should be cost neutral with this
additional rental income that we've got
in and and the immediate focus is is on
the rent orientation and some of the
disposal surveyors for the capital
receipts for for repairs and maintenance
but
the additional money that we get in when
we get closer to that 800 900 000 figure
is for people to do stat further work on
statutory compliance project managers
decarbonization officers
um and um
more compliance and audit data
management work
thank you Mark and thank you for members
for your um comments I think the higher
level analysis would be really useful
perhaps we could have an update in six
to nine months when you're kind of in
full swing that gives a good couple of
quarters work
um that would be great and the
recommendation is that the government's
audit committee notes and makes comments
on the appropriate of this update please
can I have a proposal under seconder
proposed by councilor town in seconded
by councilor Yates unless I hear any
objection I would say this is approved
perfect thank you
um moving on to a gender item five we
were due an ICT security update
um by Dan Evans the officer
unfortunately he can't make it tonight
due to illness
um we will be moving this item to the
next meeting but Chris did you want to
do any sort of brief I can give a very
sorry Chad I can give a very
um quick overview of where we are with
it Dan has provided me with the with a
note
um I believe the the update Council
leaves I think this came from a question
you raised a couple of committees back
around the additional risks around
homeworking of of officers so
um Dan Evans is our our head of ICT
within the shared service that we've got
with Canterbury and Dover
um Sudan has set up the main sort of the
additional risks that we've got working
at home compared to a traditional office
environment they're mainly around
physical controls rather than technical
controls and what I mean by that are
things like machines being left unlocked
or non-officers having sites of
confidential information that may be on
a screen people they may live with or
devices being at windows that people can
pass by and then the more technical
aspect of that is around
um home Wi-Fi not being secure enough
because of the security that people got
in place we do have some technical
controls in place that help combat that
we use Citrix for a lot of our
operations that puts additional layer of
security in place we've got us a single
sign-on now solution a place called OCTA
which effectively means officers only
have to put passwords in once so when
we're talking about people seeing
screens there's reduced risk of that
because I'm officer only putting a
password in once a multi-factor
authentication
and then the council's general
network is very well protected in terms
of the firewalls that we got in place so
over and above those controls the
digital team that Hannah Thorpe director
of comms heads up are working alongside
ICT colleagues to look at trying to get
some information and further training
out to staff to try and because a lot of
actually is fairly standard
um
yeah you know the low-hanging fruit
stuff that we've that we've been hearing
on earlier but in this context cyber
risk people just it can be Mass attacks
people Mass Force Brute Force attacks
people trying to spam their way in
getting hold of people to click on links
all that kind of stuff so there's some
awareness training that we're going to
be running with staff to make sure that
their their vigilance and looking out
for those typical types of risks not
clicking on links in the emails so that
is that is ongoing and the other thing I
can say in terms of security is it was
there was a decision taken to keep
um the ICT security team in place for
the for the next year so you may be
aware that the ICT service has been
brought back in-house the shared servers
have been disbanded but the actual
security team is going to main for one
further year as a a shared service just
while those teams establish themselves
in-house to give ourselves a little bit
more resilience because you don't want
to affect change too many things at one
time but it is it's one of those things
that's an evolving landscape as you put
more controls in place that you know the
the Cyber uh criminals they become more
sophisticated and try and top Trump
those uh controls that we put in place
but it's something that's high on
harvest register and we continue to to
monitor but um that Dan will be well
placed to add more detail that's just a
very brief update he's able to give me
he's happy to come along to the next
committee if you still want to hear from
him
perfect and moving on to agenda item six
the coarsely internal audit update
report
um Simon Webb will introduce the report
thank you chair good evening members
this is our regular quickly internal
audit update report summarizing the work
undertaken by the use can audit
partnership on your behalf together with
the performance of the partnership to
the 30th of September
if I could draw your attention to the
table on page 13 that summarizes the
four new audits completed during this
quarter we're very pleased to conclude
substantial Assurance in the areas of
HMO and selective licensing credit to
Bob's team and in particular Richard
Hopkins their substantial Assurance with
no recommendations for improvement
pretty much as good as it gets in terms
of audit assurance
payroll staff are undoubtedly your
biggest asset and of course the salary
bill is one of your largest areas of
expenditure so very pleased to report
substantial Assurance over the internal
controls in the payroll system
we concluded reasonable Assurance in the
area of digital and cloud computing
obviously an emerging issue within most
organizations
and we also concluded reasonable
Assurance in the area of waste vehicle
Fleet Management so that covers things
like the mot and servicing of your
refuse Freighters and Associated
vehicles
follow-up is a very important part of
audit work we don't just take
Management's uh word for it that they've
implemented recommendations we go back
typically about three months later
and undertake a follow-up review
we've heard a great deal this evening
about rent reviews and Commercial let
properties I was just looking back to
see when we last ordered that and it was
actually in October 21 and we concluded
limited assurance and highlighted the
backlog of rent reviews epcs lack of
kpis
the follow-up was undertaken in April 22
again with limited Assurance so that was
reported to this committee
um I'm very pleased to hear from Bob and
Mark this evening that improvements are
now starting to take place
so follow-up is a very important part of
our work
during this quarter we completed six
follow-ups and they're detailed in the
table on page 17 and page 18.
one area of concern is Cash collection
you'll see on page 17 that at the time
of the original audit we concluded
limited Assurance
unfortunately after follow-up that was
still limited assurance
one of the appendices to this report is
recommendations outstanding after
follow-up that's on page 25 and over the
page onto page 26.
unfortunately you can see from that that
we've struggled to get management
response both at the time of the
original audit and indeed the follow-up
so there are controlled weaknesses there
and we're not receiving much in the way
of management Assurance we don't have
the relevant director here this evening
but it is an area of concern that needs
to be addressed by this Council
in terms of progress against the plan
the agreed 2223 internal audit plan
that's detailed in the table
on page 21 and subsequent Pages please
to report that as at 30th of September
we had completed 41.75
of the agreed plan slightly below the 50
half year Target I can update though
that we ran the figures at closer play
today and the against the eight month
Target of 66 percent we were up to 64
completion so we're well on target for
very healthy plan completion by 31st of
March next year will be in well
um
other appendices to the report
um page 28 that shows the areas
um where we've concluded limited or no
Assurance as part of the of previous
original war deaths and we've yet to go
back and do the follow-up follow-up most
of those work in progress things such as
CCTV tendency and Estate Management
prepares of Maintenance than it
Community Lotto so they should be coming
forward to in the case of all four of
those the March meeting which I think is
8th of March next year
final appendix to this report is a
balanced scorecard of key performance
indicators for the East Kent audit
partnership
I mentioned probably the most important
one of those which is plan completion
and as I say we are showing very healthy
progress against that it also shows
details about time spent on staff
training continuous professional
development and also as part of each
audit we undertake a client satisfaction
questionnaire and the details of those
sets his faction questionnaires are
detailed on page 30. that concludes my
presentation chair I'm happy to take
questions on any of the issues raised
from Members thank you
thank you Simon uh straight over to
councilor Whitehead
thank you chair and thank you very much
for this report
and it's just
a request for further detail really in
relation to the one of the follow-up
reviews
so with electoral registration election
management
we've moved from original Insurance
level of reasonable to a revised level
of reusable but obviously we have
significant changes coming up this may
and I think currently 45 percent of
councils are expressing significant
concern as to how that will be managed
so I was wondering if
there's any information in relation to
how those changes are going to impact
and what has been addressed Within
the follow-up thank you
thank you councilor obviously any
internal audit is generally a backward
look at the systems of internal control
in this case covering both electoral
registration and election management at
the time of the audit I think it
probably would need an update in terms
of the changes moving forward either
from the Democratic services manager or
perhaps the monitoring officer
foreign
thanks Jeff
um yeah thanks to the report just two
questions first one on you mentioned the
cash collection being a
what is
uh you mentioned the control measures
being the kind of issue with the cash
collection what what are the
implications of that for example is it
their risk that some of the money is
disappearing and uh going missing
um so what's the kind of worst case
situation there if we don't resolve it
and the second question on some positive
news
um you didn't mention the food safety
has gone from substantial to no
Assurance to substantial Assurance which
I think is very good news so I just
don't know if you've got any comments
there and
um
a little bit of background there'll be
good thanks
thank you counselor
in terms of cash collection
um there was
um quite significant lack of information
being provided by the cash collector
particularly in terms of pool tickets
from machines
whenever a cash machine is opened it
automatically produces a ticket that
tells you how much money should be in
the box if you're not checking the
sequential run of those tickets you
don't know if those boxes are being
pulled in between and money being taken
out you also don't know if the money in
the box that is being counted and banked
For You by The Collector
is everything that is due to you so yes
there is a potential for money to go
missing undoubtedly
um
because um those those tickets have now
arrived unfortunately they've all
arrived all at once uh months and months
worth of them if it's a job that if you
keep on top of on a daily basis it's
fairly straightforward
um not the most interesting job but it
is an important job
um to suddenly be inundated with a
mountain of paperwork undoubtedly would
put pressure
on the teams to process
there's also some vat implications in
terms of how the income has been coded
due to lack of information from the cash
collector fat status of on the street
car parking and off street car parking
are different it is important that we
code it and separate it correctly
thank you for reminding me about food
safety um yeah very positive Improvement
there by the food safety team virtually
everything was substantial at the time
of the original audit the area that was
no Assurance was related to gdpr it
basically it was a software issue that
um prevented them from deleting old
records in accordance with their
retention schedule largely outside of
our team's control within the council
that has now been rectified and so
everything else has moved up to
substantial assurance
thank you thanks
uh Chris thank you Chad yeah just um
just on thank you for that Simon I just
wanted to add a little bit more context
um just from the service fortunately
Penny button the service director can't
be here tonight she's um not not
available
however I think um without being trying
to be too
um critical the supply has has struggled
to meet the expectations of the
contractors set out
um in Simon's report we are working
closely with them to reconcile those
those issues with the cash collection as
Simon said we've got a big box of
receipts that we now need to go through
but in terms of
um it's set out on the report that the
management response has not been timed I
think we acknowledge that that's that's
something we've slept on but has been a
real deficit of Staffing in parking
um the two most senior managers within
that era have been on maternity leave
um leaving a real shortage of management
there and obviously you'll be well aware
of the short shortage of management and
the interim Arrangement we've had at
corporate management level and we are
trying to address them as best we can
but unfortunately some things have
slipped because of the the the
availability of Staff resources
can I just quickly come back um just
yeah thanks to that update Chris I think
I'll probably speak for everyone here
when I say it would be good to know full
stop that we are on top of it like from
a certain date forward I think the
historical
review is one piece of work that needs
doing but
we probably need to know on a month by
month basis are we now on top of it and
do we have any risks of uh money going
missing
from what we can see and we don't think
the issues are substantial but there
still may be some reconciliation to be
done that doesn't obviously we want our
controls to be absolutely watertight
um but happy to
um you know bring this back obviously
we've had a follow-up and it's still at
limited
um I don't want to put words in the
committee's mouth but it's it's for you
to decide as to how you'd wish for this
to be progressed
foreign
ER
yeah well firstly I'd like to um thank
you and and recognize what you said
about the fact that you had in your
report previously highlighted the issues
around the corporate property that we
had earlier and I don't think any of us
mentioned that during that debate so
thank you for that it sort of highlights
the value of your
your update every quarter
um now the question I had
I wanted to ask about the um update you
gave tonight related to the HMO
substantial Assurance which I think we
all agree is really good to hear one of
the points in fact the final bullet
point
you mentioned uh that there are
Arrangements in place to ensure that
unlicensed hmos
are identified an appropriate action
taken and I just wondered if you or the
Mr Porter were able to let us know
how many have been identified
in a the last period maybe the last year
or last couple of years and what action
has been taken
on those occasions thank you
I'm further don't have that information
with me to hand but I I can get that
from the team
um save both the numbers
and the the act the specific actions
that um that the team have taken on
actions I think you know that what I can
say is that the enforcement protocol
that the um the private sector housing
team work by
um
includes both informal action in the
first instance and we would always seek
to resolve issues informally and then
formal action across the range of powers
that are available to the council under
various legislation so informal action
obviously is US speaking to the owner
and saying this needs this is a premises
that needs to be licensed please submit
your application and then if they don't
submit their application we would
consider appropriate enforcement action
but I've got the numbers for you yeah
thank you that'd be that'd be great I
mean it's not an urgent query I've just
interested to know thank you very much
Council Yates
um yeah sorry just following up on the
cash collection point and I think the
mention of recommendation is that
like from my side I like to propose that
we do have
um considering there are discrepancies
of 15K
and the cash collection is limited
Assurance if we could have an update on
that the next meeting I think that would
be uh
um sensible if anyone wants a second
yep very much that's literally what my
notes just said as well so we're on the
same path and I think that was seconded
by cancer Elise
um perfect are there any other comments
or questions to make
perfect and the recommendation is that
the reports um be received by members
that Learners consider were appropriate
requesting an update from the relevant
director as discussed to the next
meeting of the committee in respect of
any areas identified as still having
either limited or no Assurance after
follow-up
um
please have a proposal and a seconder
proposed by Council leaves seconded by
Council Hopkinson unless I hear any
objection I will take this as approved
perfect
moving on to agenda item seven is risk
management Chris Splinter will now
introduce this report
thank you chair and personally I just
wanted to start offering my apologies to
counselors for the late circulation of
this supplementary agenda item which is
the annex one to the report that sets
out the
um the rest that score more or score
less than eight
um or more after mitigation but not on
the main corporate risk register the
reason for the delay is as Amy our
insurance and risk officer reported at
the last committee meeting we've
undertaken or implemented a new approach
to risk management what that resulted in
was a lot more risk coming forward onto
the corporate risk register for us for
our review subsequently that needed a
lot more officer attention and scrutiny
to make sure the way we're presenting
those risks were fit for public
consumption because some of those risks
are
uh are fairly serious in nature even
after mitigation and we wanted to make
sure anything out there couldn't be
misconstrued misconstrued or
sensationalized or spun in any way that
could be detrimental to the organization
so that's the time uh the reason for the
time delay so if I can just take you
through the main reports uh the Coursey
update to risk management
if you turn to page 34 that this is a
new edition you'll see some quite
colorful tables on the charts presented
there on page 34 on page 35 it gives a
little bit more information about how we
arrive at the scores that you've been
previously presented in Risk Management
reports before so the first table sets
out how we arrive at different
likelihood scores so how probable is it
something's gonna happen all the way
down from a low score of one if it's
rare up to very likely if
um if you get the triceps work four
there's a bit of a description there is
this where and when we think it would
attract those scores the following table
below that at 3.8 sets out the impact
that that might happen if one of those
risks did happen
um so all the way at the top you've got
severe down to minor and the different
sets of headings of the types of risks
impact for the organization whether it's
reputational strategic well-being impact
on Service delivery Finance or
compliance so to give you just a flavor
at that so looking at the finance the
one I'm obviously most familiar with if
a risk happened then it would mean that
we'd lose uh more than half a million
pound we'd class that are severe so it
get the full marks all the way down if
the risk was less than 50 000 pound if
the risk actually happened we'd only
give it a score so we then take the two
scores we applied so for impact and
likelihoods and we timed them so with
the the product of the two numbers and
then we map that out in the table on
page 35 under Section 3.9 that gets the
risk scores so we show you in this
report the scores that are extreme so we
consider these are extreme risk of the
council said and that Redstone top right
hand corner risk rating 12 or 6 16 so it
means they've got a likelihood of likely
or very likely and they've got an impact
of significant or severe
so actually looking at the risk
themselves set out on page 37
um I think there was a question I can't
remember from which Council a while back
ago when are we ever going to see one of
these risks go down it might have been
new Council Ghana I'm pleased to report
you can see there are a few risks that
have gone down now um starting with the
obvious covid-19 although we are aware
of it and it is a risk that looking at
the Matrix we consider could be high
some may even say moderate it's not an
extreme risk to us anymore just because
the way the pandemic has developed and
we've now entered into epidemic uh
territory the other two risks that
reduce our political stewardship that's
partly due to the success of cross-party
working that we've seen throughout the
last period of
um well it's pretty much throughout this
whole four years I think that we've had
this Council in place but also the fact
that we're pretty close to the elections
now it's highly unlikely we're going to
see a change of leadership in the next
five months although I may be counting
um chickens are holding my breath too
soon uh that one may come back to bite
me and Ash won't thank me for it but
um the organization is a bit more of a
stable place we're not going to change
your leadership for a while and given
the upcoming elections a change of
leadership is less likely there are some
new risks on here that's because of
um partly because of the way we've been
um approaching the risk management
process but actually just because some
of these risks have Arisen so looking at
corporate risk number 19 EPC energy
performance certificates it's very much
linked to the topic that Mark covered
earlier in terms of rental income that
we can get we need to make sure that our
um our properties that we're renting out
have appropriate energy performance
certificates in place and that they are
performing at that level otherwise we're
not able to generate a rental income So
that obviously presents a finance also a
service provision potentially and a
reputational risk to us and then the
other new risks that we've got on there
manston Road uh building there was an
environment agency inspection there uh
set out some of the uh so sorry just a
bit more detail there on page 42 5.9
um
in its extremists the worst case
scenario here would be that the depot
potentially could be shut if the
environment agency thought uh it wasn't
fit to happen we're not at that
territory that's the as you can see the
light could at three I wouldn't say that
it's likely that is the most extreme
risk but we're actually looking at is
possible disruption to it if we're not
able to address some of the impacts or
the concerns that the EA have raised
around the site we've already addressed
the number of them and we've got a
deadline to
um address the remainder of those by the
end of or close to the end of this
calendar year and we are working through
those but it is a risk that is only
appropriate that we flagged to this
committee because if we weren't able to
meet those conditions obviously worst
case scenario the depot could be closed
down I'm not professing in any
um certainty or with any
expectation that that is going to happen
I think we've got the measures in place
to avoid that happening but it is a risk
that the committee given its terms of
reference should have presented to it
and then the other risk that is new is
on our Net Zero strategy this is a risk
that we're not able to meet the
commitments that we've set out in terms
of our climate change pledge and also
the
Ambitions and commitments that we've
made within our Net Zero strategy there
are another of mitigating actions that
we've got in that but very to meet them
we are very much reliant on external
funding being made available to us
across a number of our service areas and
initiatives where we're looking to move
to low carbon delivery I mean Mr Port
will be well aware in terms of what
we're looking to do with our housing
stock in terms of transitioning to Net
Zero we are we do need
external funding match fund to come in
in order for us to meet the objectives
we've got uh and the timeline and
deadlines we've got for the 2030 uh Net
Zero for our own TDC emissions let alone
The Wider District emissions by
2050. I don't intend to go through all
the risks that are on the annex would be
here for quite some time all the risks
that haven't changed appreciate the
committee has been going some time
already but of course I'm happy to take
any questions on any of the risks that
I've gone through or any of the risks
that are on the paperwork that you've
had presented to
councilor Garner
thank you thanks for the update Chris
and um our join you in celebrating the
reduction in a couple of those
a couple of those risks after the last
couple of years
um one thing that I mean obviously that
there is
those that the table of the risk scores
links to a bigger spreadsheet containing
each of those risks and each of those
highlights the type of risk they are
whether they be Finance compliance or
whichever it would it might help
us I think just looking at this but if
if there was some way of highlighting in
each of the wrists with a with a single
letter for yeah reputation or strategic
yeah or some other form of indicating or
just set out in the narrative the type
of risk that make it the clarity of the
committee that'd be helpful thank you
Council Yates uh thanks chair just just
[Music]
um
question on the homelessness risk um
just because because the director's in
the room and I thought I could uh might
be squeeze my information out
um
do we know the current number of
households living in temporary
accommodation and is this
is this the highest on record or how are
we looking in comparison with
historical figures on that
um
and do you think that we can get any
progress with this is kind of it is
related to the risk is that KCC are
currently auctioning off their some of
their housing property
and it seems nonsensical to me is if we
had a nice kind of authority we wouldn't
have one we could use that property
ourselves as TDC as opposed to
our current situation where KCC are
auctioning off property which we could
be using for temporary accommodation so
I don't know if there's any comments on
that at all thanks
um so on the first question
um we've got a weekly sheet and the team
complete so I've always got figures kind
of within a week of
um any point so um the latest update
I've got is 197. so slightly down from
the highest point but still
clearly not where we want it to be
um
we had a we were up in the 190s
previously about three
years ago three just before the
implementation of the homelessness
reduction Act
and then the strategy following the
implementation of that new legislation
was very much about investing in
homelessness prevention and it saw
some great success in getting the
numbers down and then we've seen this
latest Spike really following
um it's in the issues in the report
related to covid changing patterns of
where people live and where they work
changing the behavior of landlords
leaving the sector either selling or
moving into short-term let and cost of
living issues and and rent increases
um and actually I see in the in the
latest budget announcements from
government there was announcements about
benefits increasing with the rate of
inflation about what government haven't
done is changed the local housing
allowance rate and you know you'd think
that that would have also been increased
in line with inflation in the private
rented sector but it absolutely hasn't
and that is going to make it even more
challenging
um
yeah it's always disappointing to see
another public sector body put housing
assets or land to the market without
consulting us and
um you know I think we would always want
to have a conversation with our public
sector Partners about how we might work
together on some of those so on assets
like that and you know um particularly
housing accommodation leaving the
affordable sector and going into the
market you know clearly we want to talk
about that and our housing strategy team
would be happy to work with
the County Housing associations other
public sector partners that maybe have
got accommodation that they don't
that doesn't suit their needs and they
want to dispose of we'd be happy to have
a conversation about that
um we don't currently have
um any Acquisitions money in the
approved budget but that doesn't
necessarily mean that we couldn't do
more Acquisitions in the future and we
have used some of the development
program money for Acquisitions and
refurbishment at the moment it's all
committed to new build programs we've
got in train
but you know clearly we could allocate
in the future further resources for for
acquisitions
thank you very much
any other questions uh Council towning
culture housing associations I mean
almost is the major Housing Association
in this area
but are there any other housing
associations that you work with in the
area that could have property that we
could actually get hold of for the
homeless
are you aware
um I'm not aware of others that are
disposing of housing stock we know that
orbit are have been disposing of housing
stock mostly where
their surveyors have assessed that it
was too expensive
to to improve the energy rating of those
dwellings
I'm not sure that position really solves
the problem because you end up with a
poor performing dwelling in the private
sector rather than a Housing Association
success I'm not sure it helps obviously
the decision making is a matter for them
we have
um
we certainly would be happy to talk
about considering AC acquiring some of
those if our program permitted it I was
going to say we have I think we have
taken some units from orbit but I'd need
to check that
we've got other active associations in
the area
um
um so Riverside Housing Association
um Southern housing Town and Country
housing Amicus all have got developments
and properties in the area I'm not aware
of any of those others that have had
disposal strategies
any other comments or questions from the
panel
great
um Chris just on the manston road Depot
obviously that's quite a significant
risk go forward would it be possible to
request an update in a future meeting
just sort of we can
what make use of having risk highlighted
to us really and then we can kind of
sure yeah just uh I think that's a good
idea just uh for a little bit more
context around that risk I probably
should have set out the environment
agency has a grading in terms of how
serious their concerns are one being the
worst for being or it's a bit iffy
um we're at three so certainly not what
not a one if it was a one that's they're
coming in and shutting the organization
down
um all the way down to four so we're not
at the top of the scale I just wanted to
sort of stress that but they obviously
do have some concerns around the
operation at the Depot but I'm happy to
uh invite the service director to the to
the next meeting to give you an update
cool
um
so the recommendation is to approve the
review of corporate risks and discuss
the annex risks and obviously the
recommendation as well to invite the
service director at a later meeting
please can have a proposal and a second
to approve the review proposed by
councilor Duckworth selected by
councilor shrub unless I hear any
objection I will say this is approved
great that is approved moving on to
agenda item eight it's the mid-year
review for
2022-23 treasury management and annual
investment strategy and we're going back
to Chris pondell thank you right so
we've got two treasury management items
between us and the end of this meeting
so I try and keep it Swift right firstly
also because this paper's already been
two cabinets went to cabinet on the 17th
of November presented by councilor David
Saunders
um just some quick highlights for your
attention
um so this is a backward look to the
mid-year point of the current Financial
year at that point we had 20 million
pounds worth of external borrowing on
our books didn't take out any further
borrowing during the first half of the
year but we paid off 169 000 so that's
reducing slowly looking at the second
half for this financial year will
continue to some monitor options for
borrowing but it's unlikely that we will
borrow given existing market conditions
um so
um other side of that in terms of
Treasury management Duty around
investment so investment balances are
high they're at 57 million pounds at the
moment which is really high that's
largely because if we've got some grant
funding Margate Town deal leveling up
money that's coming in advance of us
spending it that will Whittle down over
um the next few years that has set out
on the next financial uh report they've
got on Treasury management
um there's a few techie things in here
about lease arrangements and Lease
accounting which is horribly boring and
horribly Technical and they won't go
through in any detail but I'm always
available to answer questions on it if
anyone has any uh trouble getting to
sleep
um the final thing I need to report
minor breach on our investment limits
um so we have a six million pound limit
that we can have an investment with one
particular counterparty one investment
at any one time
um there was an issue where
um the interest that we received from
would Max that the limits we had six
million invested with a particular
investment and instead of them paying
the interest to our bank account they
stuck it on the investment balance so it
went over it by 4 385 pounds between the
first of June and the 8th of June we
said don't do it again that that's
difficult for us they did it again
between the first of July and uh the 4th
of July and we had 5 300
35 pounds excess so that we're hoping
that Third Time Lucky they've got the
message and it's not going to happen
again these obviously are relatively
minor breaches given we've got six
million pounds with it
um and they're they're internally set
limits but they're still ones that I
need to report if it was to happen again
we would stop dealing with that
counterparty effectively
that's it on that
um item happened to take any questions
members any comments
Council Elise
yeah thank you thank you Chris um just
on that last point I suppose um
talk about the repercussions of if that
breach happened again is the
repercussion that we just we we wouldn't
deal with that
effect yeah yeah effectively
um there's no repercussions in terms of
us being fined or subject to any
sanctions because they're internally set
limits we could say actually we're going
to have work it's all depending on our
risk appetite and how much we're willing
to so we've got 57 million pound that we
can invest we're saying we're only going
to stick six million with one party if
you're a really if you really liked it
the committee went you know what we're
gonna in our next report treasury
management strategy you can go no limits
stick whatever you want I could have put
57 million pound with one counterparty
obviously that is high risk because if
that counterpartly goes Belly Up you've
lost all your cash typically we own
invest with a very high grade
Investments anyway so that risk is low
what it means is we've breached the
limits that are set out in the strategy
so I've got a obligation and a
requirement to report that back to this
committee as the committee that's
responsible for what ultimately advising
Council as to what those limits should
be it's the breach of our own uh
reporting limits but in Practical terms
if we it happens again we won't deal
with that counterparty
when was the limit last reviewed
it's reviewed annually and that's in
this next report
councilor Hopkinson
thank you Joe
um just on this I didn't know the term
this is a counterpart yes sorry it's uh
that's all right yeah
um because I was wondering if uh if I
was under the impression in last meeting
we should we'd be able to have a look at
what those uh Investments are yes my
apologies I can I can circulate that to
the committee and bring it to the next
meeting yeah okay all right okay
thank you councilor
uh if there's no further comments um the
recommendation is that the committee
notes and makes comments on it as
appropriate the support and access
um
I think recommends this report announces
including the potential and treasury
indicators that are shown and the
proposed changes to the 2022-23 treasury
management strategy statements to
council for approval and obviously the
recommendation for Chris to come back at
the next meeting to talk about the
Investments
please can have a proposal and a
secondary to approve the review
proposed by Council Hopkinson seconded
by councilor Yates unless I hear any
objection I'll take this as approved
cool moving swiftly onto a gender item 9
draft treasury management strategy
statement minimum Revenue provision
policy statement and annual investment
strategy for
2023-24 that's a bit of a mouthful
um introducing Chris Blundell
thank you chair so this is the forward
look this is the annual review that
we've got as an opportunity to change
some of those limits or other approaches
that we want to take unfortunately this
is still in draft form but I didn't want
to not bring it to this committee and
give you the opportunity to talk to it
the reason for that is that the next
time this committee meets in March this
strategy will have been formally
approved by Council so Council has the
ultimate responsibility but I wanted to
share the form that it's in at the
moment for you to give you the committee
the opportunity to ask me any questions
about just our treasury management
strategy in general just some headlines
coming out of it we're going to spend a
lot of money over the next few years and
that's going to need to be fine that's
appropriately so you can even see uh in
terms of our capital expenditure just
page 71 right to the bottom key
reporting items to include 92 million
pound capital expenditure over the next
three years that's a huge sum of cash
largely pretty much evenly split between
the HRA and the general fund that split
is set out on page 76 under Section 2.1
and you can see the amounts that we'll
be spending across the general fund and
the HRA so look in the general fund next
year a lot of that money the 30 million
Pounders associated with the regen works
that we're doing Town deal leveling up
that kind of thing HRA Mr Porter would
be a better place to speak here but
there's lots of improvements we're doing
around fire safety and other
improvements the tower block works but
you can see there's 92 million totals up
from 23 24 across those three years
that's an addition to a budget 51
million pounds in 2223 and what I can
say from quarter one monitoring of the
current year we've not got on with
spending that money as well as we would
like to have done so it's likely the
majority of that is going to be slipped
into next year so the reality is when
this is properly set
um we're probably looking at spending an
excess of having planned expenditure
plans um sorry in excess of 100 million
pounds for the next three years on the
capital program which is uh quite
significant uh to say the least so the
table below that on page 76 just sets
out the sources of that funding you can
see there's a lot of money there grants
and other contributions to the general
fund 24 million pound as I mentioned
um it's mainly related to the leveling
up program to regen works and then we've
got reserves on the HRA 16 million pound
that's money that's already set aside
for the program of works I was talking
about earlier then the bottom line talks
about the amount of money that still
needs to be financed over that period of
time you've got 25 million pounds so
we're going to need to find borrowing
effectively to fund that either using
our internal resources or going out to
the market to do that
um
in terms of some context then there's a
nice jazzy chart on page 78 uh this pie
chart here
um I'll try and make this a little
simpler so if you consider this uh chart
a bit like your own property that you
may or may not own or let's say a
hypothetical property
um its total value is the whole circle
the uh the blue bit is the revaluation
Reserve that's the increase in value of
your property since you bought it so
since we bought our properties they've
gone up in value equally equal to the
amount because half the value of all our
properties is reevaluation gains and
then the red bit that's laid Paul CAA
that's effectively the mortgage element
you paid off and the yellow bits is the
mortgage you still got left to pay
so we've got 18 of our mortgage sell out
standing against the value of our
properties we're looking to do a
remortgage go to a broker
um if we were doing all in one go which
of course we don't you'd say we've got
an 18 loan to value
um in terms of our the value of our
assets and the value of the borrowing
that we need to take out
um looking at the table on the page top
of page 79
um you see those investment balances I
was talking about being around 51
million pound
um for the end of uh last year they're a
bit higher mid-year as I just mentioned
in the previous reports looking forward
across the medium term we think that's
going to drop as I said we'll be using
some reserve some grants will be used up
we're expecting we're going to look to
maintain investment balances around
about 35 million pounds but that may
change depending on on whether we decide
to borrow externally or use our own cash
balances to fund our investments that
we're talking about no change to the
minimum Revenue provision which I won't
go through because it's another uh
really tacky thing but happy to take any
questions on a later date and then
you'll see throughout the rest report
there's some bits highlighted in yellow
that's because and it says link view of
rescheduling to be inserted here or
otherwise link are our treasury
management advisors and we're still
waiting on that piece of documentation
to be provided to us so unfortunately
the report still is largely in draft but
there are some key messages I can sort
of take out in terms of our Trend our
strategy our overall approach for
managing our capital expenditure our
borrowing crimes over the next few years
but this report will be going to Cabinet
in January and then to Council in
February for approval as alongside the
overall budget but happy to take any
questions
love to hear your feedback of anything
you'd like us to consider and I can take
that away with the portfolio holder in
terms of preparing the overall strategy
for cabinet and council's consideration
Council towning
um
looking at these figures 92 billion and
24 billion over period of
2326
we just listened to the director of
property where he's also looking to
increase his requirements of expenditure
and there's no guarantee that for what
he wants to do with the reviews and so
forth that he'll be able to fund what he
really is after
uh I'll be being brutish about taking so
much commitment toward bearing in mind
the global situation as we said to this
world today not looking very healthy
so that's a very good question
um some of it will be built into here
already because we have Capital we have
within our Capital plans planned
maintenance that we have every year that
we are going to spend on our assets what
we have seen is unfortunately in recent
years that hasn't been fully spent both
in terms of Revenue and capital budgets
that's largely linked to the Staffing
restrictions that uh Mark peace was
referring to earlier it's not necessary
because the finances haven't been
available to deliver those schemes of
work the Staffing haven't been there to
deliver it to give you an example in
terms of our reactive repairs budgets
that was reduced by a hundred thousand
pound about two years two or three years
ago because they weren't spending the
budget although we know there there's a
need for it it's not prudent to set a
budget that you know it's not going to
get spent because effectively you're
charging the council taxpayer to raise
the budget that you know is not going to
get spent we've got reserves set aside
for some other work as well but that
doesn't set us that doesn't just
dismissed the need to spend some of that
money what I what I am hoping as section
151 officer to finance a lot of those
Capital works that Mark piece has
referred to we're going to be able to
get on with disposing some of our
Surplus assets that we don't need
anymore or that we're not best placed to
use that there's a better there's an
organization whether it's Community
organization or a private sector
organization that's better place to run
and use that asset we can sell those
assets and then we can use those
receipts to invest back into our stock
rather than having to undertake
additional borrowing because as you said
it's not the best time to be taking on
additional debt at this moment of time
we will use we will because of the
increase in interest rates so our
strategy remains that we will look to
use internal borrowing so that's our own
cash balances that we've got take
advantage of that rather than having to
go out to the market and and look to
take Onyx uh further debt
Council Yates
um yeah uh thanks for this Chris and
thanks for the off the opportunity to uh
suggest improvements the I'm just
concerned potentially around the um
the points around ethical investment
doesn't seem to be particularly
um
substantial I would say it just it feels
not not no I don't know how true this is
it feels it's a bit of kind of lip
service
um
uh so it'd be interesting to
to know more about how like ethical
investment taking into account when
we're when we are investing our cash
into funds are we ensuring they're not
invested in fossil fuels um
and uh whether this could even extend as
far as uh the council's pensions but I
know that's managed by KCC
um so it's not potentially relevant but
um yeah if you could uh potentially
flesh out how that paragraph about
ethical investing will flow through
thanks yeah happy to take that away
um we can have some further
conversations apart far
our conversations with the portfolio
holder about that
um what I would say around uh ethical or
ESG as it refers to ethical social
governance based Investments it's
something we look to do but the
framework that we operate the Prudential
code and the treasury management code
dictates that we have to
um prioritize security liquidity and
yield in when we're looking to place our
money so although we want to consider
those Investments when I'm looking at it
if I've got something that looks
um better from those three pillars
that's what from a treasury management
perspective we are bound to sort of
consider as our primary objective that
said we have although it's not reflected
in this mid-year report because it's
only recently happened and we're
obviously into the second half of the
year we have just placed
um
uh two million pounds but I can't
remember the counterparty
um we have placed two million pounds one
on three months and one for six months
whether in a social Bond it's one of the
main High Street Banks it may be habc
Barclays or Lloyds can't remember
exactly one when we bring back the
um less than the next committee I'll be
able to tell you exactly who it is
um but we were able to place it with
them because the actual differential
between the yield on their standard
deposits and their ESG deposit was was
marginal we took a look it took a really
small hit or haircut as they like to
call them financial terms really small
uh Trim in order to be able to place the
rates weren't that much lower to go for
the SG so we're able to justify on that
that basis because it wasn't costing us
a lot of money but we're still able to
tick those ESG boxes
thank you very much
councilor Ghana
let's raise the question for me actually
you you mentioned
I can't remember exactly the the phrase
you used but you have to weigh up
uh against the ethical investment the
return you you can get by
plane terms not being ethical
Investments
it's a statutory
thing or is that I mean could could the
council make a dis make a decision to
say actually no we've not we don't want
to do that we actually want to put our
ethics above our
make as much as we can
um there's a whole Myriad of different
legislations in place some of it is I
can't remember exactly offhand but I can
look into this specific issue and report
back to the committee some of its
statute stuff that we have to understand
you follow it some of it is
um statutory guidance where it says you
have to give consideration to XYZ so it
doesn't mean you have to do it but you
have to show you've considered it rather
than just going off Rogue and doing
something else as long as we've I think
it's the latter in which case as long as
we've demonstrated we've considered that
we could potentially do something
different
but again that would be a decision for
full Council when they approve this
treasury management strategy
okay because that that might be handy a
full sort of analysis of that might be
handy for the new Council to consider
when elected in May yeah
thank you councilor
any further questions or comments
nope great
um so the recommendation for this report
is uh recommend this report and and
annexes including each of the key
elements listed which are I'll read them
out the capital plans Prudential
indicators and limits for 2023 to 24 to
20 25 26 including the authorized limit
Prudential indicator the minimum Revenue
provision MRP policy the treasury
management strategy for 2023-24 20 25 to
26 and the treasury indicators the
investment strategy for 2023 is 24
contained in the treasury management
strategy including the detailed criteria
the capital strategy for 2023-24 and the
non-treasury Investments report for
2023-24 please can I have a proposal
under seconder
proposed by cancer duck were seconded by
councilor Lee's unless I hear any
objection I'll take this as approved
that is approved that concludes the
business for tonight's meeting I declare
this meeting closed at 2042.
um good night